[Music]
on this monday night the long road to
reconciliation
the first meeting between indigenous
delegates and the pope if you don't
forgive
uh it eats at you a push to ease the
pain the kremlin accused of poisoning
peace talk negotiators i think that
russia has no regard for human life as
some ukrainians turn to nuclear reactors
for refuge breaking their silence it was
the single hardest decision that we made
that night three rcmp officers testify
at the nova scotia massacre inquiry
and the oscars historic highs i cannot
believe i'm here and the flow blow oh
wow
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
dallas flex hog
pope francis stands right in the center
of the metis delegation after the first
in a series of historic meetings at the
vatican talking about the role the
catholic church played in canada's
abusive residential school system
good evening and thank you for joining
us the pontiff listened while three
survivors shared their stories acting as
a voice for the some 150 000 indigenous
children that were forced into
residential schools more than half of
which were run by the catholic church
when we invited pope francis
to join us in a journey for truth
reconciliation justice and healing he
repeated truth
justice and healing and i take that as a
personal commitment
there are 32 delegates in rome
representing metis inuit and first
nation members their goal is not only to
get a formal apology from pope francis
but also a show of solidarity from the
catholic church to move forward together
crystal gomezing has tonight's top story
a new handcrafted future is the goal of
the metis delegation meeting with pope
francis in vatican city mutual respect
for culture and tradition with specially
crafted papal red elk hyde beaded
moccasins if he is willing to walk with
us then we'll be willing to walk with
him
[Music]
metis and inuit survivors of canada's
residential schools and elders delivered
that message today people like angie
creer who told the pope about her early
life in a residential school as well as
martha gregg
there is need for people to heal
[Music]
and there has to be a point of
forgiveness from both parts
of both parties
because if you don't
forgive
it eats at you
the abuses suffered in those schools are
well documented horrific and have
permeated through generations and
bringing back the voice of all children
the two spirit the
lgbtqia plus as i sit here that voice
has been lost for a very very long time
the call for an apology is not new but
was one of the many actions urged as a
part of the final truth and
reconciliation committee report
cassidy karen says words alone can't fix
things
but they can open doors part of that
will be
providing unfettered access to church
and residential school records so that
we're able to piece together
our history in a better way an estimated
150 000 inuit metis and first nations
children were sent to residential
schools
many did not return home the first
nations delegation will meet with pope
francis thursday the day before all
delegates will get together with his
holiness where they could learn pope
francis's next steps
crystal gamansen global news london
a 24-hour crisis line is available to
support residential school survivors
that number is toll-free you can speak
in confidence that number is
1-800-721-0060
prime minister justin trudeau is
traveling to the williams lake first
nation in the bc interior this week the
nation's chief announced the trip two
months after findings of an
investigation on the grounds near the
former saint joseph's mission
residential school revealed 93 possible
unmarked burials the 900 member nation
says the trip is a long time in the
making but did not reveal any further
details
prime minister trudeau spoke with
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
today about canada's commitment to
ukraine's defenses and sanctions on
russia civilian casualties are climbing
the mayor of mary opal says in his city
alone 5 000 people have been killed by
russian attacks and 160 thousand others
are trapped
both sides are getting ready for another
round of peace talks but as redmond
shannon reports they come as russian
forces intensify airstrikes and target
critical humanitarian and supply routes
valentina clambers into what's left of
her apartment
the 70 year old has lived in mariupol
since she was born
what do we do now she says i don't want
to leave but there's nowhere to live
here
it's thought 160 000 people are trapped
in the besieged and destroyed city but
on monday ukraine did not open proposed
humanitarian corridors blaming russia
for what it called provocations along
escape routes
but just as peace talks are set to
resume in turkey news reports that two
ukrainian negotiators one of them an mp
and russian oligarch roman abramovich
suffered symptoms of a suspected
poisoning after talks earlier in march
the men reportedly complained of eye and
skin irritation i'm not surprised
unfortunately
and i think that russia has no regard
for human life and it will continue to
use tactics like this to scare people
the wall street journal reports russian
hard-liners are suspected to be to blame
in the past two decades russian
opposition figures and defectors have
been poisoned
most recently the now jailed russian
opposition leader alexey navalny in 2020
the kremlin always denied involvement it
all only adds to tensions ahead of talks
in the wake of a significant offer from
vladimir zelinsky
the ukrainian president saying he is
willing to discuss the neutrality of
ukraine subject to a referendum this is
a real concession on the ukrainian's
part but it won't be just
neutrality it will have to be
accompanied by western security
guarantees and this is a really sticky
issue in other words somehow be
protected from invasion without being
inside nato but before all that the
russians would first need to leave
ukraine in moscow the kremlin described
u.s president joe biden's suggestion
that vladimir putin be removed from
power as alarming remark biden was
unapologetic for saying it was him
expressing his moral outrage dallas
red been shannon in london thanks
a top advisor to president zielinski
says ukraine will make no concessions to
its territory some 200 kilometers west
of the besieged city of mariupol lies a
small community it's home to one of
ukraine's four active nuclear power
plants as jeff semple explains people
are seeking safety there
just days after russia invaded ukraine
natalie prescott income and nick fel
fentoff fled their home in kiev and came
here to stay with nick's parents in the
city of eugene ukrainsk at the time they
thought it was the safest place they
could be because it's right next to a
nuclear power plant it was some thoughts
that
russians won't be so
i don't know crazy to take over the
power plant nick's father is an engineer
he and nearly half of the city's 40 000
residents work for the south ukraine
nuclear power plant
while many ukrainian cities have
witnessed mass evacuations yusuno
ukrainsk has seen people moving in this
volunteer helping to distribute aid just
arrived
i'm not afraid he says the russians
wouldn't risk shelling this city it's
too dangerous even for them
we met people from across ukraine who
have come to this city believing that it
might be one of the safest places in the
country right now during the war because
the russian military wouldn't dare to
attack a city with a nuclear plant but
then three weeks ago
it did
on march 4th russian forces shelled a
different nuclear plant europe's largest
sparking a fire and fueling fears of a
meltdown though the safety systems of
its six reactors were never affected
after russia's army seized control of
the plant it advanced towards another in
yusuno ukrainsk i remember i didn't
sleep i i
i was always checking and updating youth
after coming within 30 kilometers of
this city russian forces were eventually
pushed back and ukraine has since
retaken control of the larger plant a
close call and a wake-up call
at that point i knew that
you can expect anything from them i
don't know it's
scary the couple says everyone they know
is now stocking up on these potassium
iodide pills which protect against
radiation exposure they've also set up
mattresses in the halls away from the
windows but they're staying put
when it comes to a potential russian
attack or a nuclear emergency they say
nowhere is safe
some more safer but still it's like i
don't know russian roulette
jeff semple global news you know
ukraine
the federal government has unveiled
lockheed martin's f-35 as its top pick
for canada's next fighter jet the deal
isn't final but it does move canada
closer to replacing its aging fleet of
cfa teams the government has budgeted up
to 19 billion dollars to acquire 88 jets
the defense minister calls that new
fleet essential to defend canada's
sovereignty
this new fleet will ensure our continued
ability to protect every inch of
canadian airspace
to meet our commitments to norad and
nato and to deal with unforeseen threats
get the job done get it finished get
these ordered and let's get our pilots
trained on them and fighting with them
because their lives literally depend on
it
prime minister justin trudeau had
campaigned in 2015 on finding a more
affordable option to the f-35 deliveries
of the jet could now begin as early as
2025.
another 2025 goal of the federal
liberals is closer to reality today
ontario signed a deal for 10 a day child
care as abigail beeman explains ontario
is the last province to commit
i'm here
we first met amaya bhatt's family when
the liberals promised ten dollar a day
child care in the last budget
the struggle to find affordable child
care was so dire the intervening year
saw the family leave toronto with the
highest fees in the country and move to
kitchener i get pictures of her playing
and learning and every day she comes
back
singing new rhymes and songs and it just
just makes me so happy the new deal
promises 10 a day licensed child care by
2025 for children 5 and younger with a
25 reduction at first 50 percent by the
end of this year i think is going to put
time back onto the table for the family
i hope it just just gets better and we
we get to the 10 a day
faster so that it just helps a lot more
families
like us every province and territory
negotiated separately with ottawa
ontario the last holdout now touting a
so-called better deal it's a great deal
for ontario parents and the right deal
for ontarians families in ontario
can know that they've got the same
quality of deal
that families who signed months ago
in other parts of the country it's good
for households it's good for business
and it's great for unlocking the
potential of women that are providing
both unpaid and
unpaid care and doing paid work so it's
a triple win experts are celebrating but
say across the country even with
promises of more spaces 86 000 in
ontario's case availability is still a
problem how are these workers being paid
so we can avoid
an absolutely at this moment predictable
labor shortage and care crisis there are
underserved populations and communities
we have huge what we call child care
deserts across the country especially as
demand grows when prices fall without a
clear picture of how many spaces were
lost during the pandemic
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in their own words coming up for the
first time we hear from the first
officers on the scene of the nova scotia
massacre
[Music]
the public inquiry into nova scotia's
worst mass shooting has resumed in
halifax where for the first time front
line rcmp officers called to the seaside
town of port-a-pick nearly two years ago
testified 22 people were killed during
the 13-hour rampage carried out by a
gunman disguised as a mountie as ross
lord reports the officers said it was
chaos
these three rcmp constables were the
first to arrive at the scene of what
became one of the worst shooting sprees
in canadian history explosions gunfire
whatever it's they sound very similar
right structures are collapsing all
around us i mean it's a war zone the
officers say they had no access to night
vision technology and no way to track
the whereabouts of other arriving
officers three 911 callers suggested the
killer was driving a mocked up rcmp
vehicle as heard by the commission where
the complainant said something to do
with an rcmp car in the yard the
officers say they didn't have enough
detail to confirm those suspicions as
denturist gabriel wartman used his rcmp
disguise to kill 13 of his neighbors in
puerto pic
as they searched for the killer the
officers left four children whose
parents had been killed alone in a house
it was the
single hardest decision that we made
that night better to find the killer
they reasoned and leave the children in
the care of 9-1-1 than to stay with them
and have everyone else in the
subdivision murdered in the chaos they
did mention alerting the general public
is there some kind of emergency
broadcast that we can make that make
people go into their basement and not go
side
there never was an emergency alert even
after the killer escaped from puerto
pick hid out overnight and killed nine
more people across central nova scotia
the next day
almost two years later the three
officers say they welcomed the
opportunity to speak publicly i was glad
to see that we were finally being
acknowledged for going in
constable patton
yeah i mean
we tried our best
it was a it was mayhem and we we tried
to
deal with things as the game same just
that we tried our best the failure to
contain the gunman and the lack of an
emergency alert are expected to come up
at a later date when senior rcmp
managers including commissioner brenda
lucky are called to testify
dallas
russ lord in halifax thanks ross
the slap that stole the show ahead the
historic oscar wins overshadowed by on
stage controversy
nova scotia-born director ben proudfoot
has won an oscar for his short
documentary the queen of basketball it's
about the late lucy harris the only
woman to be drafted to the nba and the
first black woman inducted into the
basketball hall of fame
and the oscar goes to
doom
and the sci-fi film dune directed by
quebec's denis villeneuve won six oscars
among the other canadians winning awards
montreal's patrice vermette for best
production design
but actor will slapping comedian chris
rock is what everyone is talking about
the academy has launched an
investigation and tonight smith is
apologizing to rock smith says he was
wrong and is embarrassed eric sorensen
now on the confrontation that eclipsed
the entire awards show
by the time will smith got his oscar for
best actor he had already upstaged
himself and the entire ceremony earlier
comedian chris rock poked fun at smith
and then at his wife jada's baldness
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it will smith laughed jada rolled
her eyes but then oh
a truly shocking moment
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
smith left no doubt it was no joke
appall hung over the ceremony and
probably over millions of viewers
co-host amy schumer joked later it was a
night when so much was going right coda
about a child living with her deaf
parents won best picture ariana debose
won for supporting actress and reassured
those questioning their own identity
then will smith's victory that should
have celebrated his groundbreaking
career was instead an awkward seeming
rationalization for slapping chris rock
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you gotta
pretend like that's okay reaction in the
entertainment world was swift noting
that jada pinkett smith has alopecia
which can cause hair loss sophia bush
criticized rock punching down at
someone's autoimmune disease is wrong
mia farrell wrote it was a joke jokes
are what chris rock does and rob reiner
posted will smith owes chris rock a huge
apology really disturbing the memory of
that experience of that is dominating
all the other achievements in the end
smith apologized to the academy and
fellow actors but not to rock la police
say he did not file a report so no
charges are pending smith said he hopes
the academy will have him back but some
question whether he should even keep his
oscar the academy awards have always
wanted to leave the world with something
to talk about the next day
just not something like this
eric sorenson global news toronto
they did it canada's road to the 2022
world cup
canada is making plenty of history on
the soccer field lately last summer the
women's team nabbed olympic gold for the
first time now the men have qualified
for their first fifa world cup in 36
years mike trolley looks at how they
turned around what seemed like an
impossible dream oh man was this
celebration ever long overdue
on the field and off
[Applause]
where canadian soccer fans were either
jumping out of their skin
or showing it
what's there to say other than it was
unmitigated joy dreams come true
it's hard even found on this one
it really is canada ranked 120 in the
world as recently as five years ago
today it's 33rd and going to the world
cup final in qatar for the first time in
36 years the men's national team for so
long
was known as one um that was a bit of an
embarrassment right just continued
losses mismanagement at the top but so
much of that has changed
the players are different of course only
one atiba hutchinson was even born
before 1986. there's a lot of players
that have been through
so much so many like lows
that we've gone through together things
really started to change when major
league soccer expanded into vancouver
toronto and montreal which in turn
created developmental systems more
common in europe it gave a home for
players like currently injured superstar
alfonso davies to hone their skills
but the winning didn't start until the
infectiously positive manager john
herdman took over the program after
leading the canadian women's national
team to success
i told these boys right at the beginning
we've got to give this country something
to believe in
they lost hope they lost faith
but we're a football country now
let's hold back on that declaration for
a bit
or maybe he's right
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm dallas flex tonight's
here canada is elk lake provincial park
in bc
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
night have a good night
[Music]